single and
available single and available yes
available
have single and available that's me
that's me I'm single and
available I'm single and available if
anybody wants to
know you can stop me if you
want oh thank you I was I was trying to
okay I'm going to I'm going to go now
okay I will thank you what did he say I
will okay I'm single and available
though all right okay I think we're
going to keep seeing this I think we're
going to keep seeing women approaching
men yeah I mean because arita have to
right yeah cuz men men can't approach a
woman nowadays without having to worry
about getting me toed without having to
worry about ending up on Tik Tok or
being called a creeps